hablemos de la aproximación cuando x es
muy pequeña la aproximación cuando x es
pequeña es un método de aproximación
usado para resolver problemas de
equilibrio tal vez lo más importante a
recordar y con lo que me gustaría
empezar es que la aproximación cuando x
es muy pequeña no siempre funciona
trabaja mejor y generalmente deberíamos
usarla únicamente cuando nuestra
reacción es fuertemente favorecida hacia
el producto
o hacia el reactivo entonces en este
punto han de estarse preguntando ok
bueno y como sabes tú cuando la reacción
se favorece más hacia los productos o
hacia los reactivos bueno la respuesta a
eso es que depende del valor de la
constante de equilibrio acá entonces si
algo favorece fuertemente al producto
eso significa que acá es muy grande y
con grande me refiero a que está en el
orden de 10 elevado a la cuarta o más
aquí en particular hablaremos de casi
nuestra constante de equilibrio está en
términos de la concentración molar y
claro de forma muy similar cuando
decimos que algo favorece al reactivo
eso significa que casi es muy pequeña
así que en su mayoría tendríamos
reactivos y no tantos productos cuando
casi es muy pequeña es decir si casi es
menor o igual a 10 a la menos 4 entonces
estas son las situaciones en donde la
aproximación x pequeña funciona muy bien
y el valor de café se encuentra entre 10
a la menos 4 y 10 a la 4 no funcionará
muy bien y querrán usar un método
diferente a lo mejor que eran usar la
ecuación cuadrática o tal vez quieran
usar la aproximación sucesiva eso no lo
veremos en este vídeo pero lo veremos en
otros vídeos por ahora veamos cómo
funciona la aproximación cuando x es
pequeña bueno el primer paso es suponer
que la reacción irá en el sentido que
sabemos que irá basándonos en el valor
de k entonces supongamos que la reacción
va en un 100% hacia la formación de los
productos o de los reactivos dependiendo
de si acá tiene un valor chico o grande
el segundo paso es usar la información
que ya sabemos del paso 1 para hacer
nuestra tabla hice concentración inicial
concentración en el cambio y
concentración al equilibrio bueno
después en nuestra tabla hice hay que
calcular x suponiendo que
es muy pequeña por eso el método se
llama aproximación cuando x es pequeña x
es pequeña
y vamos a entrar en más detalles pero
seremos más específicos en un momento
cuando hagamos un ejemplo y en el último
paso que es muy importante muy muy muy
importante es revisar el resultado yo
normalmente hago eso sustituyendo la
concentración al equilibrio en café es
decir en la expresión de la constante de
equilibrio así nos aseguramos de que la
concentración que obtuvimos como
resultado tenga sentido y además que
coincida el valor de k con el que ya
conocíamos entonces para darle más
sentido a todo esto vamos a ver un
ejemplo un ejemplo cuando tenemos una
constante de equilibrio muy pequeña
bueno eso significa que casi es menor o
igual a 10 a la menos 4 entonces como
nuestra constante de equilibrio es muy
chica eso nos dice que al equilibrio
tenemos más reactivos y no muchos
productos en el recipiente donde ocurre
la reacción entonces para eso
ejemplo la reacción de la que hablaremos
hoy es yodo gaseoso y 2 que está en
equilibrio con 2 y menos también gaseoso
y el valor de ca para esta reacción en
particular a la temperatura que nos
interesa es 5.6 por 10 a la menos 12 ok
miren este es un número muy pequeño y
definitivamente es más pequeño que 10 a
la menos 4 así que podemos usar la
aproximación cuando x es pequeña y
supongamos que ya tenemos un poco más de
información sobre nuestra reacción
sabemos que la concentración inicial del
y 2 gaseoso es 0.45 molar y sabemos que
la concentración inicial de i - es
entonces basándonos en esto vámonos paso
a paso para usar la aproximación cuando
x es pequeña vamos a suponer que la
reacción se lleva a cabo al 100% ya sea
que se favorece hacia los productos o
hacia los reactivos aquí sabemos que
tenemos más reactivo si empezamos con
reactivos y nada de productos bueno
podemos suponer que al equilibrio aún
tendremos un poco de reactivo cambiará
un poco así que un poco de esto se
convertirá en menos podemos decir menos
x para una concentración de y 2 que se
convierte en producto y ese menos x se
convierte en dos moles de y menos
pero observen no esperamos que x sea muy
grande y esa es la clave para poder usar
esta aproximación entonces si sumamos
esto para obtener nuestras
concentraciones de equilibrio nos queda
0.45 molar menos x para 2 y 2 x para la
concentración de y menos ok ahora vamos
a usar nuestra expresión de café para
calcular x suponiendo que x es muy
pequeña entonces casi para este problema
en particular es la concentración de
nuestro producto y menos al cuadrado
porque acá tenemos un 2 como coeficiente
entre la concentración de y 2 y si
sustituimos las concentraciones que
tenemos en nuestra tabla y se nos queda
2x al cuadrado entre 0.45 molar menos x
hasta ahora no hemos hecho ninguna
aproximación pero ya es el momento vamos
a suponer que x es muy pequeña y
específicamente vamos a suponer que x es
mucho más pequeña que 0.45 molar eso
significa que es 0.45 molar menos x es
aproximadamente igual a 0.45 molar
entonces lo que estamos diciendo es que
x realmente no cambia mucho la
concentración de y 2 al equilibrio así
que esto simplifica mucho nuestra
expresión de café porque nos queda 4x al
cuadrado en el numerador porque elevamos
2 al cuadrado y x al cuadrado y en el
denominador ya no tenemos x y eso hace
que la ecuación sea más fácil de
resolver esto es igual a 5.6 por 10 a la
menos 12 5.6 por 10 a la menos 12
excelente entonces ahora lo que podemos
hacer es multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por 0.45 y podemos dividir
ambos lados
entre 4 así nos queda que x al cuadrado
es igual a 6.3 por 10 a la menos 13 y si
sacamos la raíz cuadrada de eso nos
queda que x es igual a 7.9 por 10 a la
menos 7 molar esta es nuestra x ok y
ahora el paso más importante claro
además de hacer nuestra aproximación
necesitamos asegurarnos de que nuestro
resultado sea correcto porque hemos
cambiado algo
dijimos que x es muy pequeña y la hemos
ignorado en la ecuación bueno en una
parte de la ecuación así que claro
necesitamos asegurarnos de que la
suposición inicial nos dé una respuesta
lógica entonces nosotros obtuvimos que x
es 7.9 por 10 a la menos 7 y dijimos que
eso era mucho más pequeño que 0
45 lo que al parecer es verdad porque
estamos hablando de seis órdenes de
magnitud menores a 0.45 así que hasta
ahora todo bien pero podemos asegurarnos
de que realmente sea correcto revisando
nuestra respuesta entonces vamos a
sustituir el valor de x y nuevamente
calculemos casi nos queda que casi es
igual a 2 por x que es igual a 7.9 por
10 a la menos 7 molar y todo esto al
cuadrado entre 0.45 molar menos x es
decir menos 7.9 por 10 a la menos 7
molar si multiplicamos todo esto nos
queda que casi o bueno al menos lo que
yo obtuve es que casi es igual a 5.6 por
10 a la menos 12 y eso coincide con lo
que teníamos originalmente en nuestro
problema entonces esto nos dice que
nuestra aproximación fue muy buena
obtuvimos un valor de x con lo que
podemos calcular las concentraciones
correctas y ver qué es otra razón por la
que debemos revisar nuestra respuesta es
que nos dice que no cometimos algún
error matemático lo cual es muy fácil de
cometer en este tipo de problemas